so there's more modes and evolved than
just hunt Mary I was unaware of that
until recently Chris evacuation mode
let's talk about this because it's
actually kind of an amalgamation of all
the individual modes you can play first
off evacuation it's five matches strung
together five people play through the
same five people the same four people
are always the hunters the same one
person is always the monster but you can
switch match to match and it strings
them together it's like hey we're on the
planet cheer it's totally borked all
these monsters are going crazy we need
to evacuate the place and so it starts
with hunt that's the mode that's been
demo'd all over the place it's the mode
we've talked about tons of times but
once hunt concludes the winner gets a
bonus that's right there's a lot of
connectivity between these five
different pieces it's not like you're
just playing one giant hunt they've made
it a little bit of a full campaign and
you could probably find comparisons with
left 4 dead 2 it's meant to be played
over a longer period of time with five
people and each of these pieces either
give you a bonus or give the opponent a
bonus for the next round but let's talk
about a bad tooth first round you get
out of the hunt let's say the monster
winds they might get like a bunch of
eels have now been released into all the
water so going into any water is gonna
cause problems or if the hunters win you
might just get this other soldier dude
who like shows up and gets eaten yeah
I'd like it but can totally fight on
your side for a while and also could be
eaten by the monster they'll tip the
balance they'll show you like we're
putting one little handicapped point in
the hunters favor or an hour 23 because
it's really not going well for him you
know these behind-the-scenes fixes they
seem subtle enough where I didn't
technically feel them but I mean the
matches were a little closer each time
that's true and so after the first match
you get to vote on one of two choices
sometimes hunt will be a choice
sometimes one of the other two modes
will be a choice first up is nest on
this there are six eggs scattered around
the hunters are trying to destroy the
eggs the monsters trying to protect them
until the time limit runs out the other
wrinkle here the monster can hatch
egg and spawn a mini Goliath minion to
help them kill the hunters yeah the
minions are like less powerful they have
less health but nevertheless they're
very aggressive and difficult to deal
with and a huge pain in the butt so it's
an interesting tactic for both sides you
see because unlike hunt where you're
kind of just trying to duke it out
between each other and this one you
might want to fight the monster you
would just be going after egg after egg
after edge you know the monster is
trying to evolve as fast as possible so
you can take out these hunters and
protect his little legs right because
remember the monster is at a slight
disadvantage at the beginning of the
match and then over the course of the
match as the monster evolves and the
hunters abilities stay the same the
balance is tipped flip side option is
rescue another mode that sort of takes
those nest roles and switches them now
it's the hunters who have to search for
survivors which are incapacitated humans
all throughout the map and then escort
them to evacuation pads they're trying
to get out five survivors the monster is
trying to kill five survivors and again
there's a time limit all these survivors
are played by AI and they can be
incredibly frustrating you can revive
them and think that you're totally on
your way to winning and easily they'll
get stuck something we learned is that
if the monster gets close to these
survivors they will go into that we've
been calling fear mode or by panic mode
and they literally just run the other
way
it could be the opposite direction they
just freaked the hell out which the
evacuation should their credit like if
there's a huge squid monster attacking
these people next to me I want to run
away but so aggravating when you're
trying to corral that survival it's too
bad ironically though when you were the
monster and I was a hunter that was one
of the ones that we want because we were
distracting you enough with our hunter
that we were kind of able to just take
our people by and as long as we get our
five it's considered a win so this
sounds like a nice interesting take on
just the typical for view one scenario
yeah it definitely changes the
objectives which changes the pace of the
match and we were even talking about
splitting up dividing and conquering all
these strategies that make absolutely no
sense in hunt all the sudden well maybe
you could find a way to make them work
in nest and rescue so the first matches
in evacuation mode start off with a hunt
the next three matches are determined by
voting all players get a vote and then
it always ends the same way with defend
your defending these giant generators
and massive power source then you get
three of them all together you're bound
to lose a few but the goal is to just
hold them off as long as you can because
there is a time limit for each of these
pieces what the monster gets he gets
minions he gets little goliaths every
minute or so keep spawning two of these
things that are coming at you so in
addition to taking on the monster you're
also taking on these men
you're just trying to stop all of them
from taking down these generators and
could kill the monster with the mascara
bet is while you're killing the monster
if the minions take out your power
generator you're going to lose anyway so
it's kind of just even take it's tough
for the hunters but they also have those
automatic turrets to help them out and
for the monster I mean hunters get to
respawn they get to come in a dropship
and that dropship time is accelerated in
defend they come back in much more
quickly than they do in other modes so
even if you even if you would abduct
someone away as great or manage to down
somebody I they can the hunters can hold
on and try to defend these generators
and now of course they're staged so once
one goes down a door goes down and it
opens the next one and so like rushing
to the next one it was a really powerful
tactic with Ray because of that warping
and also getting in there and just doing
your super nova damage speed is huge
it's also important to notice that the
monster starts at stage three so there
is no evolving on this final stage
you're just immediately going into the
main battle of defending these giant
generators so what's the climactic
encounter and at the end you know
whoever wins you're gonna see this video
of like either the monsters over running
the hunters or the hunters fending off
the monsters and getting everybody out
okay uh and then that's that's
evacuation it takes about maybe 45
minutes on the short end hour and 15 on
the longer end and they really want it
to feel like this sort of needy strung
together experience did it did it strike
you that way I mean I'm gonna tell you
those cut
were so enjoyable to watch I loved it it
does kind of give me that feeling like
when I used to play left 4 dead it is a
nice enjoyable sequence and it makes you
want to finish it to the end and that's
what they wanted and I think they
succeeded you won't start it and not
finish it you'll want to go through to
the end and see who actually remains
victorious because you can win the first
four and lose the fifth one and you use
and it has happened happen to us so you
never know what's going to happen on
these so it's exciting and interesting I
really enjoyed it